بعد اعدام علي رضا اكبر المثير للجدل
وردود الفعل الغربي المهدده تظهر تطورات
الاحداث في ايران ان عمليه الاعدام ما هي
الا مقدمه لصدع متوقع في هيكل النظام
الايراني
وليس ادل على ذلك ما سرب من حديث اكبري مع
القاضي المكلف بمحاكمته
فواحده من التهم التي اعدم اكبر بسببها هي
حصوله على معلومات سريه عن الدوله من امين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي هشام خاني
مقابل زجاجه عطر وقميص
وهنا كان سؤال اكبري البدايه للقاضي اذا
كان شمخاني سرب هذه المعلومات اليه فلماذا
لا يحاكم معي
لكن رد القاضي كان مفاجئا اذ قال للشاكي
ليس لدي القوه لاستدعاء شمخاني لكنني
سادمرك انت
طبعا كل هذا بالاضافه لما تعرض له اكبر من
تعذيب لفتره طويله ان انتزعت خلالها
اعترافاته قصرا
السؤال الذي يدور الان بين دوائر
المتابعين هل كان اكبري هو الهدف امشي ام
خان نفسه
ايران انترناشونال قالت وفقا للوثائق حصلت
عليها من داخل الحرس الثوري ان الاطاحه
بشمخاني هي الهدف الاكبر مما حدث لاكبره
وحتى الشبكات التابعه للحرس الثوري على
تلغرام تناولت معلومات عن اقاله الرجل لكن
المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
نفى ذلك تماما
بل ان الحديث امتد الى خليفته القادمه وتم
التركيز على وزير الداخليه احمد وحيد
باعتباره صاحب اكبر الفرق
ويرى معارضون ان النظام قد يكون في مرحله
محاسبه من يعتقد انهم خذوه خلال موجه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
الى التدخل لاخماد الاحتجاجات
ووعد بالسعيد لتقديم مزيد من الحريه
وتحقيق بعض مطالب المحتاجين هذا النهج لم
يرق لصقور النظام الذين راوا على الدوام
ان القبضه الحديديه هي الحل لعلاج كل
المشكله